putting people in a bad spot
brings my attention over to the view
where even one of the big Libs they're
all lives on The View but one of the
most openly liberal people on The View
Sunny Hosten is finally willing to admit
that the bidens are dirty
people are going to be shocked I I
completely agree with that I think that
there has been
shocking all right though I I I think
that there has been some impropriety I
think that there are instances when
Hunter Biden in an attempt to show
access to the vice presidency the vice
president's office made phone calls to
Daddy those have been taped I think we
have the situation uh with uh his work
in Ukraine we have the situation with
his work in China there's no way that
political influence wasn't a part of
that I don't like nepotism across the
board I mean what's good for the gooses
good for the gander and so I understand
that there is some real concern there
but what is upsetting to me is that
Kevin McCarthy and the Republican this
right-wing Republican party is
trivializing what impeachment is high
crimes and misdemeanors our former twice
impeached disgraced former president
accused of
um you know talking to president
of Ukraine and trying to do a quid pro
quo and trade information for arms when
his country was about to start or would
go into war with Russia that's pretty
significant
that is literally what Biden did
it's she starts out well she says look I
think the binds are a little dirty
they're peddling influence around the
world I'm willing to admit that but the
Republicans are trivializing impeachment
look when we impeach Trump we did that
because he pressured the leader of
Ukraine to give him something that he
wanted to benefit himself personally and
the threat behind that was that he would
withhold military aid as Russia was
looming in the border that is exactly
what Joe Biden did and Joe Biden
in his guileless corruption he actually
confessed to this at the Council on
Foreign Relations
they were walking out to Prescott and
said no I said I'm not gonna or when
we're not going to give you the billion
dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money well son of
a
got fired you got fired the guy who was
investigating the company that was
sending my family a ton of money in
stupid super crooked payments that
prosecutor got fired because I told
Ukraine with an aggressive Russia
looming On the Border that I was going
to withhold a billion dollars in Aid
anyway dinner's on me tonight fellas
what bar do you want to go to
that this is so embarrassing for Sonny
Hosten on The View because she look she
made her bed she's gonna lie in it she
decided that she was going to
be a little bit honest about how corrupt
Biden is
even when some of the fake conservatives
on the panel were trying to continue to
carry water for Biden she thought that
she could engage in a limited Hangout
she thought that she could
give The Observers of Biden's corruption
just a little bit of Truth and say yeah
okay you're right but he didn't do like
what Trump did we accused Trump of doing
when I guess Honey Austin just doesn't
follow the news closely enough
and the Democrats often unwittingly just
project the things that they accuse
their opponents of they themselves have
done she is describing and accusing
Trump of doing the thing that we have
video evidence of Joe Biden himself
doing sounds like Sunny Hosten and the
view is for impeachment right now text
Knowles to 200 300 for most homeowners
window replacement is not something
they've done before and for many it is
not something they want to do but rather
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive I have great
news you can now get a free in-home
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for one year text Knowles
Canada W Valley Esther 200-300 for your
free consultation to save 375 bucks off
every window and 750 bucks off every
door these savings won't last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Knowles
Canon wles to 200-300 that is Knowles
Canada wlie Esther 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at textplan.us texting enrolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details Senator Ted Cruz
unsurprisingly put this situation a
little bit more clearly and cogently
than the ladies of the view here is how
Senator Cruz
struck down one of the the biggest
talking points that the the libs are
relying on to stop the impeachment of
Joe Biden
you know the latest talking points
Democrats are are trying to trot out in
response to this impeachment inquiry is
there is no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement in the corruption
so they've pretty much given up on
Hunter yeah Hunter's corrupt as the day
is long but there's no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement that's what they're
saying now that's a flat out lie too
there's at least two instances of direct
evidence of Joe's corruption number one
you played on this show which is Joe
Biden's admission in front of the
Council on Foreign Relations that he
held a billion dollars of U.S taxpayer
get loan guarantees hostage in order to
force the firing of the Ukrainian
prosecutor who was investigating the
Ukrainian oligarch that is one of the
critical elements of bribery of the quid
pro quo quid pro quo as you know is
Latin for this for that the that Joe
Biden has admitted to that is direct
evidence that he's admitted to the only
question is is there the quid is there
the five to ten million dollars of
payments now on that there is
circumstantial evidence there are the 20
million dollars plus of payments to the
Biden family and there is also the
consistent pattern of obstruction and
covering it up very well said of course
as usual and a point that the senator is
alluding to in this clip and he said
explicitly elsewhere is
circumstantial evidence is good enough
most of the time you'll sometimes hear
people say well you can't prove that he
committed that crime you've only got
circumstantial evidence
people are convicted of crimes every
single day in the United States on
circumstantial evidence circumstantial
evidence is pretty good circumstantial
evidence is different from direct
evidence and that direct evidence is hey
uh hey I saw it snow last night I I
stayed up late and I looked outside my
window and it was snowing and I saw that
and I took some pictures of it and I
video recorded it and there's the direct
evidence of the snow
circumstantial evidence is you go to
sleep and there's no snow on the ground
as Senator Cruz says and you wake up in
the morning and there's snow on the
ground and you say okay I don't have any
proof that it snowed I don't have any
hard direct proof that it snowed because
I don't have pictures or photographs I
didn't have eyewitness testimony
but there wasn't snow on the ground when
I closed my eyes and there is snow on
the ground now so I am going to use that
circumstantial evidence to deduce it did
in fact snow
and we have got mountains of
circumstantial evidence that Joe Biden
engaged in this kind of corruption
handwritten notes text messages emails a
whole laptop from Hunter Biden giving a
real insight into these crimes and then
we've got some direct evidence as well
like when Joe Biden's admitting these
things at the Council on Foreign
Relations the only thing to do at this
point is to impeach if the Republicans
don't impeach we just look completely
feckless
so Senator Cruz is the right idea
Senator barrasso has the right idea and
the squishes need to get on board boy
what a great clip that was now make sure
that you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knoll Show podcast and show and
channel and clips we'll see you next
time